eh bien mais un autre garçon qui marche
très très fort c'est sébastien patoche
est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je vous ai fait venir
on n'a pas joué c'est manu dibango c'est
manu dibango santos aboutie du coup ça
c'est que je voulais vous remettre
quelque chose sébastien patoche vous
êtes disque de platine
sébastien batteux
[Applaudissements]
voulez-vous c'est notre disque de
platine sais vraiment pas ce que ça veut
dire mais je serais content gérard
platine or je sais pas si les gars mais
je vais au lherm savez ce que ça veut
dire du zinc de platine
ça veut dire plus de cent mille albums
vendus c'est plus de familles plus de
cent mille à 2 aujourd'hui lé plus de
100000 way au [__] j'ai envie de faire
la fête là pas vraiment un truc là
[__] c'est génial ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
les jaloux
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous entend pas
j'ai le bonheur je suis sur la béquille
je peux poser de partir c'est la tour
eiffel c'est bon sens et le brillant on
a coupé est ce qu est ce que vous pouvez
nous faire le panard comme ça ouais le
polar comme ça on arrête là j'espère que
je vais pas m'enflammer la chaîne
acquiesce mais effectivement attendez on
va le faire dans un masters - est avec
nous il ya benjamin castaldi qui est
avec nous et elodie frégé aulas
[Applaudissements]
des disques et parmi les culs et puis
bien sûr il y aura camille combal qui
sera de nouveau resté tout est bien sûr
le mâle alpha dog and funky
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]